[Musique]
ce soir on chante patron je peux y aller
oui
vas-y nounours mais ne fait pas trop de
bruit
nous vous ferons pas bull dont le cheval
tempo et ne traîne pas sinon je pars
sans toi popo pas tout se bloque content
de voir le petit dont 11 oiseaux ont
voté ce soir dont le bomba pote 421 ce
soir on s'enfonce ces gars là on a
appris des belles chansons ouais moi
c'est la fin de la journée
c'est le moment de ce projet nous
faisons comme nos amis ils seront tous
au lit nous y allons aussi sur son nuage
chère maman le marchand de sable à temps
il nous dira fermez vos yeux et dormait
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans un
rallye en hausse en juin à paunat nuit
sa branche doit se réfléchir à jamais
mon
au milieu je vais m'endormir
ils sont pas encore couché ses coquins
[Musique]
et maintenant mes chers peu vite ils
font se mettre au lit et de que vous
serez coucher j'irai vous embrasser
hégire bordés
le marchand de sable mon cher patron m'a
dit fais attention l'heure c'est l'heure
de traîneaux pas sinon je pars sans toi
voudrions
endroit
rester mais j'ai bien peur d'être accro
des fins de mois dont un beau sourire et
vous irez dormir
plus bouger rue tommy
[Musique]
monsieur non chantier bien bon à vous
tous les petits garçons avec les petites
îles
aussi nous nous situer gens qui tuent et
notre chien
en fait un groupe les ir
alors je vais vous dire voilà c'est
simple tout bonnement jeu d'horreur en
font et nous tenons à lui oui grâce à ma
manche est revenue dix mois nous nourrit
quand tu reviens bientôt j'espère bien
ah oui nous nous revient bon je voudrais
au nom
[Musique]
justin la lumière
bonne nuit les petits
bonne nuit connaît la même nuit nicolas
moni pimprenelle
et
[Musique]
à te voilà nounours ça vous a plu
patrons beaucoup vous avez très bien
chanter ce qu'ils sont mignons ce petit
sauf qu'ils sont mignons allons en route
fidèle compagnon bonne nuit les enfants
fait de pau rennes bonne nuit
[Musique]